[music playing]
HOST: Of approximately 61,000
residents in Utica, New York,
nearly 11,000 are
immigrants and refugees.
And 450 or more
arrive here each year.
Utica was a manufacturing
town in the 1970s and 1980s.
Some of our factories
began to leave,
and our population
began to decline.
But then later in the
1980s, in came the refugees.
They began to buy houses.
You drive around
East Utica, you'll
see many businesses are
run by some of the refugees
from other countries.
And would you say that they
have revived the economy?
I think it's been a godsend.
[music playing]
CHRIS SUNDERLIN:
Hi, how are you?
HOST: What's your name?
-Chris.
HOST: Do you run this place?
CHRIS SUNDERLIN:
Yeah, collectively.
HOST: Chris Sunderlin helps to
run the Midtown Utica Community
Center.
And this place is
a bit of a hangout.
It just seems like a bag of fun.
It is also a place
for anyone to come
and dance, and play, and learn.
They provide food assistance
programs and more.
Where are you from?
Kenya.
We're Somali Bantu, but we
left Somalia due to war.
That must have been a very
hard decision for them,
when they left Kenya
to come to America.
WOMAN: Did what was--
what she thought was
right for her and her family.
HOST: Yeah.
With the afternoon vibe of
this place in full swing,
Chris and I took
a moment to chat.
Are there people
in Utica who are
uncomfortable with the levels
of refugees that come here?
Yes, the wonderful older
woman who owned the house,
she asked me one day why
there were so many Asians
moving onto the street.
I said, I don't know, but
they're cleaning up the block.
HOST: And is that true?
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
If I took-- I should have
taken pictures six years ago.
HOST: And this street has
quite a high concentration
of refugees, right?
Yes, and it's all
come full circle.
There's a health clinic there.
There's three different
grocery stores.
So this area is getting better?
Yeah.
[music playing]
There's a lot more that the
United States and the rest
of the international
community can
do to more effectively address
the global refugee crisis.
We have to protect the rights of
refugees to flee their country.
And when they get to
a neighboring country,
refugees need to be able
to access education.
And they need to
be able to work.
If they can't do those
things, they're not
going to be able to stay there.
They're not going to be able
to support their families.
They're going to be a constant
risk of being returned
back to face danger and harm.
Most of us come from
immigrant families.
My grandmother and grandfather
came from Italy in the 1890s.
They were welcomed here.
Who am I not to
welcome refugees here?